welcome you all
uh we're happy that you could join us
this evening um
don't forget to check out our twitter
page at paydayterial
for any kind of dues or events held by
the chapter
uh we have something special this
evening uh our speaker
uh is vincent morber down uh hopefully i
get that right
a visit is an ai researcher at raza a
startup that
builds uh intelligent assistance uh
intelligent digital assistants uh visits
is the founder at previous chair of
paedika amsterdam
and he's a huge supporter of open source
as he's the co-author of multiple open
source projects
including psychic lego and what lies
and last but not least he's been on the
front page of reddit
well uh in this talk uh we'll go over
how raza worked
uh we'll explore word of medics in
arabic with what lies
and we'll see bulk we'll see a bit
boldly blink demo
um hope you all are excited as i am just
some logistics uh we'll allocate some
time for questions
and answers at the end of this talk but
feel free to use the chat section uh
to drop your answers and we'll pick them
up along the way
over to you visit um so thanks for that
introduction
um so what i kind of would like to do
with you all today is there's a couple
of demos that i think are just
kind of nice um but i should admit i'm
actually not a researcher
i'm actually more of the person in the
research team that helps explain what
the research team is doing
um i'll explain what that means because
it's uh it's kind of a role that's super
new and part of my job is to figure out
what i'm supposed to do
but you have to imagine the company that
i work for
raza we like to make this open source
product that allows anyone to build
conversational agents
um and that means that you know you
might have some new user interfaces if
part of the dream that we have is uh if
you are somewhat older lady and you're
not really
well versed with like navigating a
website it will be just very nice if you
can just ask
natural in the natural language form
like hey website can we can you please
fetch this for me
that's kind of the thing that we like to
achieve we just want to make
better more meaningful interactions
possible
and that's going to mean i'm going to
split this talk up into three separate
segments i'm gonna
first just give you a brief demo of how
rasa works so you kind of get an idea of
what kind of problem i'm trying to solve
after that i'm gonna talk a little bit
about well i would really also like to
be able to
have raza work for you know
not just english languages but a bunch
of them and
you know once that's done i would like
to really give you this
nice little demo that shows how you
might be able to do bulk
labeling and i think that's going to be
uh pretty cool and interesting as well
uh let me just check if this works all
right um
so just to check real quick are you guys
also seeing this red line over here
oh you're not seeing this you can see me
doodle i think
you'll see the doodles and the red line
you also see the red line here
that is interesting so i think i might
be able to fix that by
quitting screen brush no okay and if i
go to google
it is also still there i'm gonna stop
sharing my screen just real quick
because the red line is bothering me and
i hopefully if i reshare the screen
again the red line is gone
it's kind of a strange artifact
all right and share screen once more
okay i think the red line is now gone so
we can kind of get started with this
so um what is raza and how does it work
the idea behind
a virtual assistant if you think about
what might happen right
it's not so much a um
like a standard thing that you might do
in psychic learn
because if you think about what sort of
problem you're trying to solve is
you kind of have a situation that's like
this you have a person
uh sorry you have a person over here and
that person is trying to say
let's say hello and after that you have
sort of the
the robot the conversational agent
that's replying so the user might say
something like hi
first and then uh we might get a hello
back and let's say that we're talking to
an assistant that can order pizzas for
you it's like
domino's pizza or or something
then every time that a user says
something you can imagine that there's
an intent
behind it the user is saying something
because we would like an
action to follow so
if we are building a very good assistant
we are able to sort of take this text
and then classify the next action so to
say
however the next action is actually kind
of a tricky thing if you think about it
what might happen
is that the uh that while we are in this
flow of hey can i
please order a pizza that the user then
also asks
uh hey are you a human the idea being
that we might start a flow for ordering
a pizza here right so that's kind of
what's happening
we might go into this funnel but a human
is always able to interrupt the funnel
by either doing chit chat or that sort
of thing
so on one end we have this problem where
we would really like to do this
classification task well
on this text but on the other hand um
predicting the next best action
sometimes we have to do more than just
look back at what the user said before
if i look at this pizza example um if
if we ask what kind of pizza would you
like then we ask are you a human
there's kind of two actions after each
other that are supposed to follow
first the assistant needs to be able to
say well
let's answer this question and after
that uh
we should look back multiple time steps
to figure out what the next best action
is
and this is kind of the hard part of
building good assistance on one hand
we would like to be able to predict hey
what is your intent right now
and after that we would like to say well
what's the next best action going to be
that's kind of the to put it into sort
of simpler terms so
the two big sub problems as far as
machine learning is concerned that we're
trying to deal with
so one thing that i hope
just showing this to you this in this
basic conversation
is that in order to have a system that
actually can do something like this
we are probably not going to have one
csv file
that we can eventually give the site
could learn because we're doing multiple
things at once
we're trying to do something with this
intent over here as well as the actions
over here
so what we've done at rasa is we've
basically made this command line utility
where you just give us different files
and then we'll take it on from there
and what i would just like to briefly
demo is what such a
project might look like and what sort of
files you can expect
to kind of have a feeling of what it can
be like if you were to train your own
virtual assistant
and what i'm doing now is i'm just
running the assistant locally on my
laptop
you can install everything by running
pip install raza
and what i've got here is just the hello
world its project from raza itself
um if there are any questions actually
right now i could answer a few i know if
there are questions
i do see some stuff in the chat oh it's
about being recorded okay that's fine
um so
what i've got here is a rasa project and
in the rasa project there's
basically a couple of files that really
really matter
the first file that really really
matters is this nlp the yml file
and it's a yellow file where we have
examples for every single intent
so i'll just zoom in a bit just to make
sure it fits nicely on the screen
but let's say an intent that the
assistant might have is to say hello
if you want to do a greeting of some
sort and what we can then do is we can
say well
if you want to go and do greeting then
here we've got a couple of examples
these are all different ways of saying
hello so this day
and if we scroll down then we have
something similar namely
all sorts of different ways of saying
goodbye and one thing i'd like to point
out is that
um you can see that these are just
examples that you
could have typed and there's all sorts
of spelling errors that we have here
which is quite common if you're building
an assistant
and we also got one here for saying
affirm for someone wants to say yes
we also have one for saying no there's a
couple of examples we've got here
and then you know we've also got a
different intent
you can say that you're doing well and
what i'm hoping that you
might be able to realize at this phase
is that it's nice to have all of these
examples but
given that we have a couple of these
intents with examples
we might be able to use them as lego
bricks uh i
actually don't is lego a popular toy in
the
like i don't know if that's actually
something that's common just
figured i'd check um no i guess
if i say lego people know what i mean
yeah okay yeah
i just want to make sure um because the
thing is
having something as a lego brick is kind
of nice because what we can do now
using these intents is we can kind of
use it as a lego brick to construct how
a story might go
so we can have this other training file
where we say something like you know
i don't know exactly how every
conversation is going to go
but i can come up with a couple of
examples of how they usually should go
and we might have a conversation here
that's that's what this story is all
about like
um where the user starts by saying hello
and then the action that our assistant
should make is we should say hello back
and then if that is followed by the
intent hey i'm doing great
well then we should utter happy
so we can map these intents to actions
by putting them in a story
that demonstrates how a conversation
might go this is kind of like the flow
so to say and the assistant that i have
here is
isn't particularly smart the only thing
the assistant really does
is it uh it says hello then it checks
whether or not you're happy
and if you're not happy it tries to
cheer you up that's the only thing that
this assistant is trying to do
but one thing that you can kind of see
though is that we can say well the
conversation
the conversation kind of happened like
well we say hello first
then we say that i'm unhappy then i try
to cheer you up and then i ask you if
that helped
and if it did well then i'm going to
tell you this
and if that didn't help at all then i
say goodbye that's basically
what these stories tell me i'm not
suggesting this is a good assistant
right this is what these stories aren't
doing
and the way that raza is set up is that
we can at some point say well there's
basically two machine learning systems
that are happening
on the one hand we have this one machine
learning system that takes text
as input and then it does a
classification of sorts
and we call that natural language
understanding as a task
and the main thing that it tries to
detect are these intents
so just a classification task what are
you trying to achieve what's the intent
that you would like to communicate to us
and i hope you can see that yeah we've
got like training data for that
and then here the idea is well given an
intent
that i currently have
and also given the conversation so far
what is the next action that i should
take
and this is not going into an nlu model
we call this a core model
and it's a different problem because we
might need to predict multiple actions
that follow up on each other
but the idea behind the stories file is
that this is training data for the core
model so we've got one model that tries
to predict
next uh sort of the current intent and
then with this other model that can
predict the next action that's kind of
the idea
and we try to and all the models that we
have here by the way are just python
code it's all open sourced
um there's some tensorflow stuff
happening inside of this model over here
but all this stuff is open source so it
also means you can add your own models
if you would like to do so
and i guess there's like a there's one
other file that i'm just going to
briefly show you
there's this domain.yaml file and then
i'll just give like the quick browser
demo
but you've noticed in the story that
we've got these
uh intents here and then we've got this
action
and this action is something that we
have to define somewhere
by and large there's mainly two types of
actions that you can do one action is
well we just give you some text back
that's always going to be the same text
another action is well there's just this
python function somewhere
and we're just gonna trigger that python
function and whatever the python
function tells us we should send back
that's the thing that we will send back
and that's nice because it means that
you have this python code that can
retrieve items from a database
however you do have to define all of
these actions somewhere
we've defined our intents into this nlu
yaml file and we have to do the same
thing for actions but we do that in this
domain.dml file
and this is more of a settings file
where all of your actions are defined so
to say
and what i can do then from the command
line just to give like the quick demo is
i can call raza shell
and what this will do is it will pick up
a
model that i've trained beforehand
that's in this models folder
if i type browse a train it will train a
machine learning model on my behalf
and what you can then do is you can just
talk to your assistant and you can try
to break it
and play around with it
so just to give like the simplest of
simplest demos i can say hello
it says hey how are you i could say
something like i
am sad and then it tries to cheer me up
uh in fact it gives me an image so that
let's try to put that into google
see what happens
google chrome new window right if we put
that image in here
we get a cute tiger so it's trying to
cheer us up
uh and then if we go back here it asks
hey did that help you
and i can say no and it says goodbye it
follows a story that i've shown you
earlier
now the idea here is of course is that
this story that i've got over here is
super super simple it doesn't
necessarily resemble
something that might happen in real life
if you're ordering a pizza this story
file is probably going to look
substantially different there's the
hello part there's the
what pizza would you like parts can you
tell me what you would like on the pizza
what's your address
you can imagine that this story is
definitely more involved
but i hope that we see this distinction
between next action
and predicting your current intent
so let's quickly exit out of this
and what i've shown you so far is the
training data
what i have not shown you yet is the
machine learning part like what are the
machine learning components that you can
use to actually
train these systems and
all the machine learning stuff is
effectively defined in this
config.yml file and i'll uncomment a few
things here
and this is a that's not everything fits
on screen there but
but the idea is that we've got this
config.yml file and that we have
all these components that together um
are the pipeline that makes the
prediction for the intent
um i'm assuming that a lot of you are
familiar with psychic learn
would i be correct if i said that
uh yeah i guess this is this is a pretty
pretty accurate assumption
so this is like the pipeline in
scikit-learn um the only difference is
this is defined in yaml instead of
python code
lots of people say yes okay oh i'll take
that as a yes
that's really convincing yes okay um so
like a cycle and pipeline you've got
these pre-processing steps right
and we also have that here it's just
that they're a little bit more specific
towards text
so you got to imagine at the moment
what's happening is we have text that
comes
in and basically the way the pipeline
works here
is text is turned into this message
object
and every time that it passes through a
step in the pipeline
more information is added to the message
so you can imagine suppose the text was
something like
hello world
let's say that this was a text and the
first thing that happens here in this
white space tokenizer
is that the message is split up um
into this list of tokens so to say and
for english that's usually
very easy to do because you can just say
there's a white space let's
split them up into separate words and
now this message
has this tokens property that's attached
and after that we pass it through a
regex featurizer and a count vectors
featurizer these are all things you
might have heard from from scikit-learn
and what that actually does is it takes
this message
and adds some sparse features to it
so you can imagine things like okay
which words are being used and
we kind of get this training yeah this x
matrix so to say of sparse features
that's attached
and like eventually we will get to
classifiers and that sort of thing but
every step in the pipeline here just
adds another message that's kind of the
idea
and this also brings me to why i would
really like to talk more to people who
do non-english
because um you have to imagine if you're
raza like in our research team
we have a couple of data sets that we
run our benchmarks on
most of them are english some of them
are german some of them are spanish
but if i think about the different tools
that i have at my disposal here
for english the white space tokenizer
works quite well
i don't know for 100 certain if the
white space tokenizer works for
arabic as well like i can imagine that
it might but it also
might not currently we're doing some
tricks with count vectors here which
make a lot of sense for english
um we've also got this lexical syntax
featurizer
which does things like capitalization
this is the capital letter in a sentence
or is it lower case and you know i can
definitely imagine that this
doesn't necessarily translate super well
to every language
and moreover what you can do here is you
can add
a spacey component such as you get
pre-trained word embeddings for english
and i i'm really really sure that you
cannot use pre-trained english word
embeddings if you're
interested in making a virtual assistant
in arabic right
so there's all of these separate tools
that we like to suggest to people
that we think might help build you a
good assistant but
one thing that will be a shame is if
these tools only end up working
for the english language so a project
that i've started working on internally
like
this is something i'm doing to help the
research team is i'm trying to figure
out
what tools that we can add here
to also make sure that this trick works
for non-english it's not going to work
for us
if people send us their data sets
because
if you're a company or building a
virtual assistant probably your data set
is like
private data and you cannot just go
ahead and share it so it's not going to
work for us if we
ask people for data so we can run the
benchmarks so instead the tactic that
i'm trying to do
is i'm just trying to listen to people
if they say well here's a tokenizer that
works really well on my language
then i'm trying to make sure that that
is available inside of raza
what i'm also trying to do is i'm trying
to add embeddings for all sorts of
different languages
and what i'm trying to get to is i've
kind of started a project where
we have more pipeline components more
than the ones that are just inside of
raza
and the first project that i've open
sourced this year with that in
mind
whoops i need to close up this one
there we go is
this project um this project is called
rasa nlu examples
and the whole idea is that i'm going out
there to try and find
tools that should work for non-english
languages
what i've got are some tokenizers so
for thai i've got a separate tokenizer
but i've also got one for
stanza what these tokenizers do by the
way
is not just taking a sentence and
splitting it up into separate
words but what they also allow you to do
is things like limitation
so instead of saying he likes
dogs we might be able to reduce that
down to
he like and dog if you do this then your
total vocabulary size is a lot smaller
so that can be very convenient
um but the main thing that i think i've
added that a lot of people like to play
with
are these dense featurizers these are
these pre-trained word embeddings that
i'm trying to make available
in lots and lots of different languages
in particular a word embedding that i
thought was pretty cool
is this fast text is pretty cool like it
has support for arabic but there's also
this other featurizer
that's known as a byte pair featurizer
um there's a question coming about
dialects i'll pick that up in like a
minute
there's one thing i just want to show
you here um
so this byte pair featurizer what's kind
of cool about it it's written it's
created by two german researchers
and they and they have a cool topic for
making these embeddings
but what they have done is they have
taken every language that they could
find on wikipedia
and they've gone ahead and made these
pre-trained embeddings for them
[Music]
so if you go to their website
which is this one it has to load
um they claim to have 275 languages
on there and you can scroll down there's
a couple of examples but they have this
very very long list of languages
and what's cool about this is that they
also have a couple of dialects
um i'm pretty sure they can't have every
single one
but you could but here you for example
can see well there's a variant of
russian that's that's being advertised
here
um i know for example that uh
fission this that's a dutch dialect
um and and there's welsh here which is
this
uh category of languages that they have
in england is like a
an english variant also a dialect so
i remember checking this out and
thinking like oh this is great 275
languages
lots of these pre-trained embeddings
it's going to help out a whole lot of
people this is good
um but here's again something i don't
really know for sure
um these embeddings are trained on
wikipedia
and wikipedia is great because it has
like lots of language on there
but i've but if you look at the text on
wikipedia and if you consider the text
that people like to type when they're
typing into a chat bot
it is a completely different style uh
wikipedia
media tends to be quite formal um
whereas if you type something in a chat
bot it's really
informal and also it's present tense if
you're typing in a chatbot and wikipedia
is definitely more about history and
stuff that happened in the past
so already here i'm having a little bit
of issue
assuming that this might be super
helpful for chatbots and
to make things like a little bit worse
uh
what you're able to do here is you're
able to um you can select how big the
vocabulary for the embeddings are going
to be
you can also select what dimension of
embeddings you'd like to get
that's you can do it on the website but
what you can also do
is just have a look at the umap
projection
so you can sort of see how what the
embeddings compress down to
and if you have a look at arabic right
something that's a little bit weird
is there this really really big cluster
down below here
where i can safely say that these are
arabic characters like this is not
english
but at the same time if you scroll back
up
it also seems like some english is mixed
in for some reason
and then you consider well this is
trained on wikipedia
i can't guarantee that the researchers
cleaned up the data banks before they
trained these embeddings it's something
that might be happening here
and another thing with these pre-trained
embeddings i think it's not a concern
here but in general it's something to
think about
um if you look at how these pre-trained
embeddings are trained
something like uh the cat is hungry
let's take that sentence
then the way that somebody's embeddings
are trained is they
take a look at this word and they try to
predict the next
two words using this word as input
so if if i think about what's happening
here is there's some sort of neural
network
i'm just going to quickly draw that out
like so where
cat is going in here as some sort of
input where
everything here is a zero but there's a
one here we have some sort of feed
forward layer and then
we have some sort of label here that
predicts the next couple of words
but the way that this is being applied
is they predict the next word in order
um and i believe arabic is not from left
to right it's from right to left
so then i can wonder you know is this
trick even gonna work
like independent of the data quality and
the fact that there's like english still
in the data source i can also imagine
just because of the nature of the
language
we can't assume that algorithms that
work very well in english
are going to end up working very well uh
on other languages
so as i was doing my best you know to
like
properly open source all of these tools
for
raza users by taking all these
pre-trained embeddings i kind of also
very quickly came to the conclusion that
although what i'm doing is really noble
it might not be very effective
mainly because you know in the end i
don't speak arabic so i cannot judge if
these embeddings are of high quality
so i kind of needed this tool where
people can just try out these embeddings
real quick and
hopefully therefore also report back to
me if any of these tools make any sense
so that's kind of the position that i
found myself in this year
and this is also something that's been
motivating a lot of my open source work
so i'm about to do a demo with everyone
here but now might be a good time to
answer some questions because i saw some
coming in
into the group chat also i'm hoping that
everything that i've said so far makes
sense and if it doesn't now be a great
time to
to ask questions
um so someone is mentioning that aren't
most language model
using bi-directional analysis this is
definitely true
but not all of them and that's kind of
the thing that i'm a little bit afraid
of
i think even fast text at some point
takes like it looks at both the
words before and after um
but but also there a lot of those tools
are benchmarked on english so i'm
the main thing i'm trying to get across
here is that i don't think we should
assume
that the algorithms that work well for
english should also assume also work on
arabic that's the main thing that i'm
personally at least a little bit afraid
of
somebody is mentioning arafak and i just
want to point one thing out
if you go to the rasa nlu examples repo
you will see that i've added a ticket uh
for aravec
um so that's definitely something on my
roadmap i just
i would love to learn if these
embeddings make sense like if the
if you tell me they're useful and if
this is a blocker for you using raza
you can just let me know because this is
on the road map for the examples repo
um so that's a nice so i'm getting
confirmation that i should implement
this so that's a good
good sign um code switching is very
common in arabic especially for
scientific terms which could explain the
english words
popping up ah that's true actually
there's definitely some sense there i
can also like in dutch there's also
some english in the language even if
even though it's like a reference to an
english term as opposed to like
yeah so that also makes sense why they
exist that's true
um how would stories fit the example of
ordering
uh a pizza if the user differed from the
path
set um
okay there's someone mentioning a tool
real quick
just check that uh i hope i pronounced
it correctly
uh chem camel
did i spell it correctly by obed
maybe i should add nlp
oh camel my bad
but open source python toolkit for
arabic
okay um
raza nlu examples i'm adding an issue
right now that i should go ahead and
read the paper
uh just want to point out uh we've also
allowed participants to unmute if they
have something that we want to they want
to say verbally
if that's cool with your consent as well
yeah sure go ahead no like this this
would be a great time to ask questions
and
also i like this sort of feedback if
there are tools that you think i should
consider
just i like to have them like at least
on the issue list so i'm aware of them
so yeah uh guys feel free to a new to
ask a question if you have
something you want to discuss verbally
or drop it in the chat
either way is fine thank you
in the meantime
abdullah could you share the oh wait the
arabic word lies link here's
that's the one i forgot what i'm now
also
doing is i believe there was this collab
link that was shared beforehand
if you're interested in participating
and actually coding the next part that
we're going to do
what you should go yes perfect you
should go into the
chat and you should see a link and you
can use that link to participate in what
we're about to do um
there's an install command that can take
a while so it's pretty good to maybe
run that and i'm also
hearing about a lemmatizer so again i'm
going to the
i should leave it open i think uh rasa
tell you examples
github link
get a blink and i can just add that
also a limiter check
it out also vincent that is a uh
an arabic tokenizer uh that was posted
by
zayd which uh which we have posted a
couple months ago and
i think you should check it out
could you repeat the odd um let's have a
look at that one i think i have a couple
of them in the issue list but i just
want to check if
nope that one's new we'll definitely add
it
i like the logo by the way it's nice and
clean api
yep okay add it to the list add it to
the list
yeah and i think we have the creator as
well with us today
sure
uh why are there two count factorizers
okay that's a really good question
um so
there's somebody asking like they saw
the pipeline over here and i've only
spent a little bit of time on it but
they probably observed
that there is not one but there are two
count vectorizers in here so people
might
wonder well why is that one thing to
point out is that this count vectorizer
has settings that this one does not
and in particular the main setting
that's relevant is the analyzer setting
um the idea behind it is that if i have
a word like
university
if a user were to spell it differently
let's say univer
city with a c instead of an s which is
the wrong spelling then
an issue that might arise is that this
word is totally not recognized
even though it's really really similar
than the previous word the fact that
it's just you know
spelled wrongly means that it doesn't
occur in the vocabulary
so the idea is that what you can do
is you can say something like well you
know let's just instead of
um putting this word in our vocabulary
sorry instead of putting this word in
our vocabulary
let's just look at all the bi-grams like
u n
n i uh iv
v e and also the trigrams like uni
and iv iv e
v e r etc like if we put all of those
things in our vocabulary
then we might be robust against spelling
errors
and that's why usually um a lot of
people like having this count vectors
featurizer here
it's it's just a insurance policy if you
will
against misspelling that's why we have
it
i think there was one extra question um
can i ask a question if that's possible
yeah go ahead go ahead yeah so
thanks vincent it was actually a very
good presentation
um i already worked on raz for like six
months or so
when i was working on my uh master
thesis
and i think it's a very good tool uh
although the
interface isn't that good compared to
google dialog flow
i don't like google but i'm just here
talking about the interface
um anyways i think the only thing that
can be a challenge when making
it an arabic nlu would
be that in arabic the vowels the short
vowels
actually aren't written in the words for
example
one word can be written in for three
letters and it can be pronounced like
seven in seven ways and in each
pronunciation
it has a different meaning with a
different intent
so can a tokenizer tackle that issue
just so i understand correctly um
because again i'm not familiar with
arabic
um is it the phenomenon where you spell
the word the same way
but depending on where you put the
emphasis on the word it is a different
meaning
or is it is it different than that it's
a different for that for example if you
write
a word with only three letters like
there's a word in arabic it's like it's
called
it's act it can't be pronounced in
different vowels like
arabic you actually don't write the
vowels so they
what the chat what or the conversation
agent actually can't recognize
how the word would be pronounced so
one thing that um okay so there's one
thing that will help you here it's it's
a great question though
and i i'm gonna try to answer it but i'm
going to make a couple of assumptions
about arabic and if they're false you
should just say so
but one saving grace here let me just
get the drawing tool
is that we have this diet classifier
that's in here
now very basically put the die
classifier is a neural network
it has a transformer in it and a couple
of dense layers but you can imagine
right
um i can i think i'm allowed to say well
you're probably not going to have just a
three-letter word
every single utterance you're probably
gonna have like the three-letter word
and maybe two other three-letter words
when somebody's typing something back
and and even if you so so there's a
little bit of wiggle room in a sense
that well
we can at some point say that typically
even though this word has many different
meanings
usually if people use this particular
word in this particular chatbot it means
that they are referring to this intent
so and one thing that will help you out
here is typically
if you have a count factorizer uh i'm
gonna
i'm just gonna do it phonetically what
you pronounced earlier sounds like oct
which is the dutch way of saying it i
suppose i'm
hopefully not pronouncing it very wrong
but i'm approximating here
um but that that can be activated while
there might also be some other word uh
activated i'll i'll write norm just
randomly but it might be that these two
are activated at the same time usually
and since we have a neural network here
that just you know does the feed forward
thing it can at some point learn the
pattern that
only certain intents are triggered if
both of these words are activated at the
same time
that is something that a neural network
might be able to pick up so even though
the tokenizer on its own is not enough
to pick this up
as long as it's surrounded by these
other words you still have a lot of
going for you
[Music]
and there's also you know the chatbot's
not supposed to do
all of the arabic language typically
you're only focusing on a small subset
for a specific use case
like ordering a pizza for example so
typically that might be a
way of thinking about it to make it more
manageable but um
if i'm missing something here feel free
to tell me
actually that was a comprehensive
question comprehensive answer thanks
okay i will show you so i would like to
do now because i think this this might
be something that's fun for the entire
group and this we can sort of do live
coding together
um because one thing i'm kind of curious
about
you know i'm making all of these tools
so a very nice
thing to get answered is do these tools
even work and also do they work in the
same way as english
so one thing that i've been making this
year is this tool called
what lies and the idea behind the tool
is
that i want to figure out what lies in
word and banks
and there's kind of a joke in there
because if you think you know
lies lies and that's also an
interpretation of the word
um it's because lies has two meanings
that i figure it will be an
acute name because a big problem of word
embeddings is
that we for a single word you might have
multiple meanings and i'm assuming
that's the same
in erratic like single combinations of
characters can probably be a word which
can have multiple meanings
even though it's written down the same
way i'm just checking but i'm assuming
it's universal property of language
so what i've done
and that's the way that this library
works is i have a library that basically
has a data frame but for word embeddings
that
that's the whole idea so and the way
that it kind of works
is we have a language back end uh that
can be bypair embeddings it can be
spacey
anything that generates word embeddings
and
and what you can do is you can give that
language back and text
like you can say hey here's man here's
king here's brother
and if you give it a list of
strings the output of this will be an
embedding set
and an embedding set is the equivalent
of a data frame uh but for word
embeddings
and the lies library basically puts like
a lot of visualization tools
and tools in general help you make
understand if the
word embeddings that you have if they
are at all useful
and one thing that's that i've never
done before
what i'm actually kind of excited about
that i can do now i've never really
compared
uh embedding the same source from
different languages
i guess i've done it for dutch but i've
never really done it for arabic
so to give a small demo of of what you
can kind of
have and i've installed everything just
now but
um oh this has to download i think we're
gonna have to wait a little bit but
um is this thing loaded let's just check
there you go so what's happening right
now is i'm
um i'm basically configuring um
two language back ends i've got the
biter embeddings for
arabic and i've got the biparent banks
for english
you can check the documentation for
these by pair languages
the first parameter to give it is the
language code
and then in the case of bytepair you can
say well i want to have like the big
uh dimensions and i want to have a very
big vocabulary size as well
and this automatically download the
relevant byte pair embeddings for you
uh it's doing arabic right now it's
going to do english in a bit
and while it's i'm assuming that this is
happening on your screens as well
so what i just very briefly want to do
in the meantime is
show you the documentation pages um
mainly because i think it's relevant to
show that
[Music]
you know i support a lot of different
languages so
right now we'll be using bike pair
languages but i also support
gen sim anything that's supported by
hugging face
tensorflow hub is also supported there's
some bird models from the sentence
transformer package i
also support spacey and fast text so if
you can find
arabic word vectors in any of these back
ends then you can use this library to
do what you're interested in
another nice feature of this library is
that any of these
language backends can automatically also
be plugged into a scikit-learn pipeline
so that means that if you're doing let's
say
sentiment analysis you can have your
psychic learn pipeline over here
and you can just put a language backend
as a feature riser in here
and just from doing this you will get
the language uh
features like the word embeddings that
are part of the text that you feed it
um so it also means that if you're
interested in just benchmarking how good
embeddings are to predict something
then you can also just use it in
combination with scikit-learn for your
task
okay so i think this is now done
downloading
um what's pretty cool about the way this
works i'm just gonna do it for english
first
is if i wanna get like the embedding for
the word uh
king um this is the syntax you just use
the square brackets
as if it's a dictionary and we'll just
get the embedding for king
um you can also do sentences in here
that's completely fine
it depends on the language back end but
typically we add all of them together
like we add all the vectors together so
to say and what you get back is this
vector object
of this embedding object i should say
and an embedding object has a name
and it also has a vector oops
shortcut
which is just this numpy array that you
that you're probably used to
uh but this is really convenient because
one thing that i can also do
is i can say well let's just give it a
list of like
uh king
and uh queen let's say
well in disco typo in this case we're
not retrieving one embedding we're
retrieving two
and this is an embedding set so this is
like the data frame so to say
and what you can do is you can get the
length of it it'll tell you two because
right now we've got like two things in
there what i can also do
is i can say well please parse that to
like a proper numpy matrix and in this
case it'll have a
specific shape it'll be 2 by 300 because
for both embeddings we have
300 dimensions i can also cast to a data
frame there's a bunch of useful
uh utilities attached to this that's the
idea
and what you should also be able to do
and i don't know how i can do that on my
keyboard but if you take the
arabic language back end you
should be able to
[Music]
oh the right and left are also inverted
i see that's interesting
um there you go
but you should also be able to get like
the embedding for arabic and it should
just go ahead and work and you should
also again
be able to query the vector and it's
it's like a data frame but for
uh for language that's the idea
what you can also do given a language
backend and it's gonna be interesting
like i
i like to also judge a model sort of
qualitatively
but in order to do that one thing that i
typically really really really like to
do
is i like to make plots because i can
look at 300 dimensional vectors but
those typically don't have too much
information so
instead what i usually like to do is i
like to make these
similarity charts and just again show
you the code and that you understand how
it works
i have a dictionary here which
people have helped me translate uh
thanks again um where i've got the
english word and i believe this is the
correct
uh translation uh don't blame me
most of this um but i believe i have
reasons to believe this is just simply
correct so
i have the english word and i have got
the arabic word
so if i take that dictionary and i take
the values of it
well then i get all the erratic words
if i then turn it into a list well then
i can use that just like i showed you
before
to get all the vectors and all the
embeddings out
and what i what i can then sort of do as
a chart let's say that i have the
the vector sorry let's say i have the
vector for king
and i've also got the vector for queen
let's say
well what i can then do is i can
calculate some sort of similarity
between those two vectors these are two
numpy arrays
so i can calculate like the cosine
distance or the euclidean distance these
are all things that i could go in and
calculate
and if i calculate for that for every
pair of words that i have in my list
then i might be able to see clusters
appear
and if you followed all the steps so far
i hope i'm not going too
fast um but if you do that
then you might get a chart that looks
something like this
and um one thing that's nice to see is
that matplotlib is able to handle these
characters that's
definitely a nice thing um but to me the
thing that i find the most interesting
um is that if i uh
cancel if i look at the english version
of this chart
then i can see some clusters appear like
over here i see man woman that's a
pretty decent cluster
i've got some animals over here you can
kind of you squint your eyes
you can kind of see a cluster appear
over here as well
um and here we've got some things that
are about students and schools and again
we kind of see this cluster in the lower
corner
and one thing i found relatively
comforting is that if i scroll up and
out
look at the charts that's here for
arabic as well
it's certainly not the same chart but i
do
see at least the animal cluster appear
again here right
it is something that appears in both
languages
the one thing that does seem to be a
little bit different uh like english
here i would argue has like a slightly
stronger cluster for man woman king
queen brother
and there's a little bit less of that
maybe here it's it's
still kind of hard to say but it's it's
charts like this at least that
um make it even possible to compare
these language embeddings
the one thing again that i don't know is
does this make
sense to you like this might be a good
time to like start asking questions
again
like i i cannot really judge if
the clusters that we see here you know
if they're sensible or not i can see
some
overlap of what i see below here but it
feels less strong of a clustering
than what's happening here
so i'm assuming people are sort of
playing around with this and while
people are playing around if you have
questions that might be a great time to
ask as well
um i saw one question about
why we add word vectors as opposed to
average them it depends on the language
backend so
i think spacey takes the
there's one spacey version i think they
took the average and another spacey
version where they took the
um the mean it kind of depends on the
version of space
if if i'm not mistaken and like it's
hard for us to do something that's
consistent so
we just use whatever the backend
language does i think fast text adds
them
jensen might average them it depends on
the language back end
ah so this is uh this is not inverted
that's the issue if i'm not mistaken
like the it needs to be like from left
to right um it needs to be from right to
left instead of left to right
is that what people are saying
ah okay um
uh i'm going to make a note of that
people are referring to the
bd package
ah there you go
python arabic reshaper
ah this is a really cool package i am
definitely keeping an eye on this one
okay uh i'll keep this tab open and i'll
have a look
um it will be it might be nice if i'm
able to
add stuff like this to what lies as well
that makes the plots prettier that's
definitely a feature i wouldn't mind
adding
so i think we have a question from sad
that
you can unmute yourself i think that
hello can you hello yeah
yep you're there okay so so thank you
for
uh your presentation uh so uh
for my understanding uh the emptying
that you used here is
is from wikipedia right uh it's bypass
embeddings and their documentation page
lists that they are trained on wikipedia
yes so
so so i think you're going to struggle
with with the slangs
right oh definitely definitely so
so we have like multiple multiple
multiple slangs not
so we have slangs in saudi arabia also
we have slangs
with the arabic the arabic countries
so what can we do to face
this problem so so i think if we if we
want to use this
uh for example in a hospital as a
chatbot
and we're gonna assume that a lot of
people is gonna contact with
with our chatpot and so we're gonna have
a lot of
uh slangs so so how can we
uh like solve this problem
it's uh it's a really good question um
so
here's my version of the solution but i
will say like slang is also an issue in
english it's
uh like wikipedia is really bad at
simulating like actual conversation and
slang
is like a really good example of that
also dialects i think
that's what you alluded to so a very
valid concern
however here's what usually happens like
if you have an embedding
like a numeric array goes comes out
right that's how that works
but um this is just a feature
this is not the machine learning model
so to say in fact
if you have a look at this diet
classifier um
let's say that i've uh i've some sparse
features
going in from the count factorizer but i
can also have some dense features that
are going in
let's assume that the dense features are
coming from this embedding
effectively what will happen right
i'm drawing this out like very
schematically
but let's say that we have our diet
algorithm here and we're doing intense
eventually here
the only way for diet to actually
learn what is happening is to actually
look at your training data
so that means that there's a gradient
signal coming from your intents
and that are that's going to update all
the weights that we have inside of this
system over here
and if that means that certain slang
words don't exist in your embedding over
here
then it also means that your dense
representation here is just going to be
all zeros
right so how is diet going to compensate
well diet is just going to have a look
at the sparse features that you do have
because that's the only signal that it
can learn from so
how do you fix this for your specific
use case well
data make sure that your data set that
you collect is representative of the use
case that you're trying to solve
and that's the way that you're going to
get robustness in
in general the thing that is good to
remind ourselves of
is that these embeddings are probably
trained on a general use case
probably they're not trained for your
specific hospital use case or legal use
case or
whatever your specific domain is these
pre-trained language models typically
don't contain the jargon that's specific
to what you're maybe interested in
so your best bet is always to be mindful
of the data quality instead
um it's i don't blame you for this but a
lot of people tend to focus in on the
oh can i get like the highest accuracy
and all of that sort of thing can i do
the grid search can i try out all these
embeddings
it's definitely fair but usually the
labels matter
way more that's that's right so so so
so i'm which be so a phd student and
my focusing on natural language
processing and
like i don't know i have an idea like
what if
we use social media to just train our
embedding so in social media we can
we can specify the location for for
example country or city and trying to
to like retrieve all for example tweets
or or paused and and then try
the way that people talk to each other
on twitter is probably not
representative of the way that people
are going to talk to your
virtual assistant right but but at least
it's like
slang so it's pro there's it's probably
better
that's that's possible um but it's but
but still for your specific chatbot you
need you
must have these labels because otherwise
you don't have the gradient signal it's
the
thing you need okay on your topic though
i do want to mention one thing
because it might inspire your research
what i'm doing currently
um as an experiment uh is i'm aware of
the fact that wikipedia is just a bad
source it's it's there i get it but it's
i don't
i prefer to have a different back end so
i've downloaded this thing called the
open subtitles data set
the data set is from movies uh and like
the subtitles that you have there
and the interesting thing about that if
you think about what is you know
captured there
it's actual conversations between people
it won't be perfect slang but there will
be some of it
but at least it won't be super formal it
won't be super historical like
a lot of these wikipedia issues you
shouldn't have with it
um so i don't know if that exists for
arabic i think
that's open source for like 60 languages
but that is something i'm currently
exploring
um as sort of an alternative to twitter
too but with
definitely the same vibes as what you're
describing
okay thank you very much thank you great
question hi
vincent this is sally hi uh thank you
lilly for for the presentation i really
like it
i came from business background uh i
used to be a programmer
before seven years ago still program a
little bit but now i'm back
an interested moment into the uh any lu
and the chatbots
i'm really curious to build something
for business focus
so my question is and sorry if it's
maybe naive but
when i look into businesses you look
into industries and you look into
specific domains when you build a
chatbot for telecom
it's different form from hospitality for
example oh yeah that's correct correct
and the problem here where where is the
the the uh
the words and the conversation coming
you mentioned about movies you mentioned
about bqe okay
are there other sources for domain based
for business based that
that we can uh get off and i'll
i'll start with english you're gonna
you're gonna love the demo that i'm
gonna show after
that's the only thing i'm going to say
it's the main thing i want to say about
it i do want to like do continue your
question
but i think i'm going to answer it with
a demo what i'm about to show you yeah
so it's simply what sources do we have
that we can
grab domain specific industry-based
specific discussions
yes we can't build intelligent chatbots
on this sure
now so so there's two things that at
least uh on raza's end that we
sometimes recommend like in the end um
let me put it this way like the one
thing that is always kind of weird about
this space
um people will interact with your
assistant in ways that you simply did
not anticipate
i'll give you an example i'm building a
chat bot in my spare time
that's a video game the idea is it's
like a text-based adventure game you
have to type what the
what the person is supposed to do and
i'm building a chatbot thing around that
and i've shown that to some colleagues
sort of start playing with it and the
point is that you pick up items and you
combine them and puzzle and
that's the point of the video game i've
shown this to a colleague
who never played a video game before but
she has seen her husband play video
games
and when she sees her husband play video
games it's usually about like
guns and destroying stuff so she thought
oh it's a video game so that means that
i shouldn't pick up items i should try
to break everything
the same thing will happen with chatbots
out there because you're not going to be
able to perfectly predict how users are
going to interact with your assistant
the unfortunate thing is that you're
probably just going to have to
carefully expose it to some users and as
quickly as possible learn from that
that's usually the recommended way it's
it's at some point i might even argue
it's not really
artificial intelligence anymore it's
definitely more psychology and like
empathy for your users that are going to
help you design a good system
that said typically if you're starting
out with a virtual assistant you
probably are
already a company and you probably
already have some data coming in from
customer feedback
like if you're a telecom provider then
you probably have like a call center
where you already got some feedback in
or it might have like a twitter account
where people talk to your brand
and that can be a really good source of
inspiration so to say and that's that's
more the
place where i might start than to just
assume everything from wikipedia
uh i found my ad we actually
for my company we had a lot of data
coming from twitter and we also had
live chat uh but what you
did is that we we are using rasa what we
did is that we deployed it
uh using menu based chatbot and
people don't really use menu they type
so
we only like we brought it i think two
months ago
and we have over 150 000 sentences
so we are actually now building rasa
using this data
so i think this is a good sounding point
to anyone who's
like who wants to collect uh training
data they can just
start like this another thing that we
sometimes do internally is
uh i mean you start out with some
intents that you think are reasonable
and then you just show it to a colleague
and again try to learn from that
that's you have to start somewhere and
your first version is probably not going
to be great but by showing it to more
and more users
hopefully you get to be able to learn
this was a nice comment thanks
um hello um i just want to add a small
thing um first thanks for the nice
presentation
thank you um i'm relatively new to them
nlp
realm i'm i'm uh i'm mostly into other
sorts of machine learning um
anyway um a while ago i
as i was starting into nlp um i was
really interested in chatbots
so i reached out to a few friends um
that's when i realized that it's not
that easy
anyway the thing is uh
with with the kind of businesses that
actually need
not just want that that needs child puts
they usually have
a huge amount of employees who actually
work
to to reply to customers
um especially in in chats
live chats live chats and customer
service
so they actually do have a huge amount
of conversation data
that can be used to train models
for their specific use cases
[Music]
the problem with this kind of data is
it's not available
openly so um so the company
and what companies yeah yeah
won't give it to you for free yes yes
and
and i will say uh privacy reasons are
good reasons i
i don't want to suggest that they should
everyone should share their data
but i do acknowledge that what you're
saying is definitely a small problem
because we can't benchmark as much
anymore
so the data is sort of available but
it's just not openly available yes
and that's a big problem in the arabic
language in general that should be
tackled
i mean i think privacy concerns are fine
right
if if you have if you have like if
you're a bank right you can't just
share every conversation that you have
with your clients
because you know a lot of stuff should
be private
um but but you are right um
but in general i think even for english
there's not
like an epic amount of good chatbot
data available i think there's more data
available for images and like detecting
things in that
uh than like a proper nlu use case where
you actually have a proper conversation
and that's something that we benchmark
against um
i so in that sense i do want to give you
a little bit of hope in a sense that
um what you're describing is also an
issue in english it's not a uniquely
arabic
problem i think but availability of data
is definitely a huge issue
that's just the fact of life that's true
um
[Music]
just to check are there any more
questions
because i kind of want to oh yeah one
more sure
i have a tiny question about um the
embedding vectors
yep um by any chance um
since those um uh
embeddings for arabic and english are
not directly related
by any chess would they be similar for
counterparts i mean um
arabic and english words with the same
meaning with the shared meaning
would the similarity be high between
them you would hope so but it's not a
guarantee
yeah um i would expect it to to be to be
more
similar in translation
yeah so so what i know is what some
people do
um is like if you're if your language
doesn't have a lot of data available
i know that some people go to like
google translate first translate their
sentence into english
and then throw that into an embedding
and then use that embedding some people
will try that
um a few issues though like you will
have to deal with this translation error
translations won't be perfect
and second the thing that usually isn't
captured very well is this cultural
aspect
so i'll give you an example if if in
europe you open up a newspaper
and the newspaper is about brussels
it's nev in that case i can guarantee
you that typically the news will not be
about brussels the city
uh typically it will be about the
european union that has its headquarters
inside of brussels
so whenever you see the word brussels
appear it's usually about politics as
opposed to it's a city
but it uses the same token now if you
were to translate this
um you might get the embedding for the
city as opposed to embedding for
the government because that's something
that's sort of missing maybe and that's
kind of the risk of this translation
unfortunately
it's not a bad idea but there's these
edge cases that you're not insured
against that's that's
that's the unfortunate fact here
um
that said um i think we've answered most
uh questions okay so um i'm sorry
for the interruption so lastly can we
compare
the similarity between arabic and
english now um
we are well so the best thing that you
can do is stuff like what i'm doing here
is and the thing is like if you have the
translations at the ready
um you can do this sort of thing
actually
i'm going to do some live coding and
we'll see if it works is that
actually no way this app i can already
say it doesn't it's not going to work
and i'm going to explain it with the
chart that you see below here
if you think about what's happening when
we do word embeddings right
one way of thinking about it is to say
well these words are going to cluster
they're going to cluster in like a high
dimensional space somewhere
and probably the word cat and dog
they're going to be close to each other
and the word
man and woman they're going to be close
to each other that's mainly because
they're going to be in the same cluster
what i'm doing here is i'm again taking
the
arabic words and i'm taking the english
words and all of their embeddings
but what i'm now also doing is i'm
applying principal components
to both of these to turn these 300
dimensional objects into two-dimensional
objects
and that way i can plot them and you can
see the results here by the way
these are like very pretty altair charts
they're
interactive you can host them on your
website but what's happening here is
that we see these two dimensions
um know that the axes are not the same
we do have this one property that at
least for english i can confirm
hey yeah all the animals are here
together
we have the university in the school
we've got the students here so i
definitely see the clusters appear
and i would also assume something of
clustering must be happening here
but it doesn't necessarily mean that the
coordinates correspond to each other
it might be that one cluster is in the
upper left corner here while it's in the
lower right corner here
again because it's clustering it's not
necessarily pointing to the same array
does this answer your question
yes it does answer but from what i from
what i see
um the arabic words and their english
counterparts are not too different
especially on dimension one so
they certainly won't be as similar but
there is a little of course
we didn't see it all of the 300
dimensions but
this might be but but does it hold for
all of the clusters
uh like where where are the animals in
arabic is this the animal cluster
yes yes exactly okay and and these words
that are now sort of close by
what are these two words um animals also
a dog and um a lion oh wait but there's
and what are what are the three here um
a kitten
um a puppy and a cat okay okay so so
this is the animal cluster
so to say yes uh and these
um man woman okay
woman in english so there's definitely
sort of a similar thing happening here
but there are things happening in the
left corner here that aren't happening
right right and cool so um
it's on on dimension one they are sort
of in this in a similar place but not in
dimensions here
exactly and it's that that makes like uh
doing numeric comparisons hard
there's no guarantee that well that they
will be in the same place
especially on the other dimensions yes
and uh and that's and that's the thing
that makes it really really really hard
that's the
the main thing that makes it harder in
fact um
a very valid question though but this is
also what makes machine translation hard
sometimes
having said that though i want to maybe
point out
one funny thing
um so
you know i'm kind of looking at this and
i'm kind of saying
you know there's a cluster here there's
a cluster here there's a cluster here as
well
and this is kind of a fun user interface
if i think about it
well there's something really nice about
being able to zoom in and out and
being able to play with this and it
helps that i've got this fancy pen so i
can actually do this doodle right
but i've been thinking like hey maybe
some of this language processing stuff
that we're doing i can give you these
embeddings
but the main thing i'm trying to do to
you is i'm trying to make people
understand
so maybe we should stop looking at it as
a machine learning problem
and maybe we should start thinking maybe
it's more of a uh
user interface problem there's something
to be said for that so maybe
considering that i have this jupyter
notebook and i can add javascript to it
maybe i can combine some stuff what i
might be able to do
is to make it easier for you to play
around with arabic embeddings and maybe
also something makes it easier
for you to do labeling so here comes
what i think is the coolest demo that
i'll be doing this year
uh i do need to
find my notebook i think it's this one
yeah i think it's this one there you go
[Music]
and if i now do the f yes okay it's
gonna work perfect
so the demo that i want to show you it
is english
however all the tools that uh are in
here
should be available for some version of
iraq as well
what i'm doing here is something that
you saw before as well i have my text
that's going through some sort of
language back end in what lies and
that's going to give me this embedding
and then i'm not going to use pca i'm
going to use this different embedded
technique one that's called umap
and it's my favorite umap it's the best
it's
something really cool that they do the
main thing that's really nice about umap
is it does the clustering
part way better uh it really tries to
separate things out into separate
clusters more
than what visible components do but the
thing i like is it's going to give me a
two-dimensional representation
here's what the charts look like and by
the way the data that i've given it here
is like data from my chat bot it's
unlabeled uh it's the chatbot that we
have on the raza website and these are
all the chit chat
examples that are in there
and what i can do now is i can kind of
zoom in i can just kind of start
exploring some of these clusters
i can say you know french other
languages
these are all sorts of questions that
users are asking
about like hey razabot do you also speak
something else in just english
i think i've got a cluster over here
that's really about finding restaurants
right there's a couple of those
the issue though is that the embeddings
that you see here are based just on
count factors so the only thing that's
being clustered
is is a certain word being used or not
and that's also why i think there was a
cluster over here if i'm not mistaken
yeah so people are asking what is your
name
and what are you doing and the reason
why those are in the same cluster is
probably because the word what
is in there which is the best way to
cluster points so
so this is a cool demo but let's let's
go for byte pair embeddings instead
and you'll notice that we do by
parameters that some of these clusters
are definitely
way more pronounced right if we compare
clusters here with the clusters here
it definitely feels like stuff has been
pulled apart more
so again we see the language thing here
that's good
and over here we see a lot of stuff
about restaurants being hungry
that's that's already better right like
it says hungry and that's automatically
in the same cluster as
restaurant even though the word
restaurants not being used here
right okay so that's that's nice that
it's clustered together not just based
on the words that have been used
but something of meaning is a little bit
attached more
but still if i kind of zoom in it's not
perfect like the proximity here is not
necessarily the same
thing as meaning so it's better but
maybe what we should do is we should use
the universal sentence encoder
we're going to go ahead and use the one
that's in tensorflow hub and the user
universal sentencing code is actually
pretty good at doing exactly this like
taking a sentence and embedding it in a
distinct way
and if i do this you know if you find me
a restaurant that's a nice little
cluster
do you know any jokes to make me laugh
that's a cluster
like these clusters are nice and
pronounced if i think about it
and if i start thinking about labeling
you know it'd be cool it'd be really
cool if i could like draw a circle
around this
and then say let's have a look at all
the data points and give that a label
and then this cluster will go away and
then we can do the same thing with this
one and we can do the same thing with
this one
so here's the cool thing like this year
i've been making a couple of open source
tools available
what i've shown you so far is this tool
that i made it's called what lies
but i'm actually pretty happy to also
demonstrate this other tool that i made
called
human learn the idea from that
tool is to make it easier for you as a
human to add rules for psychic learn
and it also has some interesting
integrations with
pandas and so here's one of the features
from human learn
you can see that there's all sorts of
clusters here what i can do is i can
double click click click click
get this little shape going and this is
like my selection box
i can put that over a couple of points
and then i can use the
and there's a trick that i can do such
that i can fetch the pandas rows that
correspond with those points
that's what i'm doing here so it seems
that all the points that i have here
just from glancing at this
they're all about time there's not a
perfect clustering here right there
might be some errors happening
but just the first 10 rows it always
seems to be about time so what i can go
ahead and do
so i'm going to say well here's a label
it's called time
okay that's these indices let's just
assign this label
and technically i've just labeled 51
data points
and if i now were to reload this chart
we will see that this cluster goes away
and i can continue on to label another
cluster and sort of inspect that
maybe just double click click click
click double click let's have a look at
these
and all of this seems to be about
restaurants i'll just call this food
we'll label that i can refresh this
again
and what i'm hoping again
this is not going to be a perfect
labeling but if you're a company
and i'm assuming there's plenty of
companies and you're interested in
making your virtual assistant
and you're in a and you're in a
non-english language then the thing that
you need
i think are not necessarily embeddings
that are trained on wikipedia
instead i think it would be nicer if you
can just more quickly come to labels
yourself
so if you think about the most effective
thing that i might be able to do to help
the community
in part i'll definitely keep open
sourcing these embeddings i'll
definitely keep doing that
but maybe i just need to make tools that
make it more fun to just do stuff like
that's something that i've seriously
been thinking about because
i think we're just going to get way more
labels from doing this
simply because labeling is more fun now
it's not this task that we sort of go ah
no i got a label
it's going to be this task where you can
kind of say hey let's explore the data a
bit more and actually understand what's
happening
and it's it's just it's childish i guess
but it's something about like drawing
and then being able to interact with it
and then like it becomes a toy instead
of a chore right that's the thing i find
super interesting about this
and i've actually timed myself doing
this like i was able to get like a
thousand data points
in five minutes again i don't want to
suggest at all that these data labels
are like
the highest quality there's probably
some mislabeling happening here and
there
um but i'm also
so that's the main thing i kind of want
to leave with i'm also interested in
looking at nlp from this angle
i don't want to suggest that nlp is just
training embeddings and making sure that
all these tools are available that
definitely helps
but the main hard part about any nlp
task in real life
is getting high quality labels that's
also why raza has this rasa x product
it's a free tool
but it's something that helps you
labeling um because in the end
it's not going to be the pre-trained
embeddings that will save your pipeline
it's getting proper labels instead and
being able to
do like high quality there i think
that's going to be way more important
so this was the cool demo that i hoped
everyone liked um
i'm pretty sure there's going to be some
more questions here but i get i've
basically given you
the main things that i want to present
there's tons of other stuff i could show
you but i think now will be a good time
to just check the crowd if there's any
uh
questions and and oh and the final thing
i kind of want to say about this
um i'm using the universal sentence
encoder here which is for english
but i have also found a pre-trained burp
model that you that you should also be
able to use for this
and i would love to hear if the
pre-trained word model plus the
human learn thing that i've just shown
you if it helps you label i like
hit me on github if you have any
feedback on that i'd love to hear it
um so we got one question from nicholas
i believe
what would be the next step uh
after the first pass of labeling oh
sure so in my mind this is useful when
you just start out right so
we might have these logs from uh
customer service we might have twitter
data
and this will help you get like clusters
going and the main thing i would argue
here is this is going to be
inspirational
for you to design your intents so the
first time that you're making your
assistant
what intents are our users actually
asking for
and and can we like put them in i kind
of like the texting frequently asked
questions
um after you've done that the next thing
is to actually show that to users and
see how they respond
and and that that's where the really uh
more important labels are gonna start
coming in
because it's um maybe it's also like a
fun little drawing to make
um so like
oh my god yeah so if i if i draw the
venn diagram right
um if the if the left dia circle here
represents
uh stuff
that we optimize
and on the other side is like the stuff
that users care about
the hardest part of data science is not
doing
this the hard part of data science is
making sure that this overlap between
these two things is big in this in the
first place
so what we've just shown is something
that's really really good to get your
first labels
the next thing you got to do is just
check if those labels matter to your
users
because it might just very well be that
you have some clusters that
translate to an intent but it's an
intent that none of your users ask for
that is the next step that you got to do
ah how to handle out of topic intense
that's a good one
um what kind of out of topic because
there's a lot of them
um one other topic intent that i've
actually open sourced uh two days ago
three days ago
ah did i close it already yeah i did
so one type of out of out of topic uh
thing that keep in mind is language
um especially here in the netherlands um
it sometimes happens that
um that the assistant is only able to
speak dutch but people talk english to
it
so that's something you don't want to
have like you want to maybe check hey is
this person even speaking the right
language
however to gather training data for
every single language out there isn't
the language that you're designing for
that's not going to be great training
data for your system
so raza has this mechanism that's known
as a fallback
this is a bit of an advanced topic but
the idea is that
when you've done your classification
with diet there's a predicted intent
you can then have a fallback mechanism
that just runs on the
side and if that fallback mechanism is
triggered it can override an
intent so the idea is for example one
fallback mechanism could be the
confidence score that comes out of diet
is way too low so
okay we're just gonna ask the user to
repeat the question because we need a
higher confidence before we automate
something
the thing that i've made here is similar
but the thing that it does
is it triggers whenever you're speaking
the wrong language and then we can ask
the user hey
whatever language you're doing please
refer back to the target language
for this assistant this is i think
if you're able to do a fallback that's i
think the nicest way
to handle auto topic um
it's still it's not necessarily easy but
i think this is a nicer way to talk
about
uh like outlier detection there's
usually a couple of these outliers that
you can define quite well
these are typically outliers that occur
very often in your assistant
and this can be a way to target those
specifically so that will be
at least my train of thought
the notebook that i just shared is open
source i'll share the link
it'll probably get to i'll add it to
like the meetup website i think that's
the easiest way for people to find it
what if a message has multiple intents
how to handle them um
so one way of thinking about this
um i'm just gonna give like an example
suppose that the intent is i would like
to order a pizza and it's this pizza and
i would also like to order
a coke like the drink the coca-cola like
it can be that that's like the full
sentence that you get and there's like a
couple of intents in there
one thing that you can do from the user
interface perspective is to say well
this is the moment where we're going to
start a form loop
where we're going to say okay i think we
got this information
we wanted to order a pizza and a drink
is this correct
so what you would do is you would
basically ask the user
i think this is what you want me to do
is it correct and if not
here's like a form where you can be more
specific
it's more of a user interface way of
catching that than a machine learning
way per se
there is a way inside of raza to sort of
try to detect multi-intent it's a bit of
an advanced use case you could
go there but usually it's more of a user
interface problem than a
machine learning one
uh hi i have a question uh
who had like for designing the stories
uh let's say we have
uh uh very different actions
for the same intent so we will design uh
different stories uh
following different um you know
steps or um based on different intent
like what's the what is the history of
the conversation right
but with that effect and predicting the
next action
like for for instance let's say that for
like i want to order
pizza uh you know
based on the entity different actions
would be
uh triggered children yes
so would that affect the performance or
because like we were currently building
our stories and we like we noticed that
um it does fail like a lot
so uh what version of browser
uh 1.10.11 ah okay then you're gonna
like this
so the way that this works this this i
i've kind of focused a little bit more
on the nlu parts but the
but what you're like what action to do
next that dialogue management
is actually a way harder problem um
however
one thing to keep in mind is that we
have this tap policy
and what's really just happening there
it's kind of like a time
it's not really a time series but it's a
time sensitive thing where we try to
look back on
more than just one time step ago to try
to predict the next best action
and that's something that we try to do
machine learning wise
it's just that it's not going to be
perfect 100 of the time
um so instead what we have is we have
this new feature in raza 2.0 that's
called a rule policy
and the idea behind the rule is that
it's similar to a story
but it's it's much more rigid a story is
meant as training data
but the rule is base is a little bit
more like an if else statement if this
pattern is detected then this is the
the action that you should take no
exceptions
i've got an example here like if
we ever see the intent goodbye
then utter goodbye should be the only
thing that we ever sent back
no matter what else happened in the
conversation up until this point
if the intent is goodbye right now then
this is the only correct response to
send back
this is a pattern matching system so you
can be expressive
it's not that it's it's not just intent
and then action you can also do things
with entities and slots here
but this would be the way to maybe try
to navigate that
i do think that you don't always need
machine learning to
predict the next best action sometimes
you can just go on fine with these rules
and what you're saying here suggests
that you might want to uh invest in this
feature
yeah i would try thank you one thing
about that by the way if uh suppose that
you're trying this feature and
you have a hard time getting it to work
um
one thing to keep in mind is we have
this forum.raza.com we have this raza
forum it's
for free you can just ask questions
there um
and i take like a half hour basically
every day to answer questions here
so if you have trouble implementing this
i would love to know because i make
educational content for raza as well
um my username here is
uh koning k-o-a-i-n-g but if you
look for vincent you should also find me
if you have a problem
post a question here and like add my
name and i'll gladly help you
sure thank you
okay
any more questions
somebody's running slack
that's fine i guess
this is it with the q a let's see
okay um if no one has a relative
question
i have sort of an art of topic question
go ahead um as i said earlier i'm just
getting into
nlp and as i wanted to to go
for chatbots i found that
i'm getting a bit ahead of myself so i
went back and started reading
jarrowski's book on
natural language processing so
any advices for going
ahead after finishing the nlp basics
that would help with uh chatbots
specific like i i want to be kind of
honest here
uh i think i started doing nlp
a year ago i think i i don't consider
myself to be an
actual expert uh i i have a research
team that some of them
in my research team have like a proper
phd uh like i
i consider myself knowledgeable and i
can do stuff in practice but i don't
necessarily consider myself an expert
what i am good at though is solving
problems um
and i think the reason why i'm good at
solving problems is that
i don't necessarily focus too much on
the nlp algorithm
instead i just try to really understand
the problem and that makes me a lot
that makes it a lot easier to pick the
solution that's the most appropriate
so the best advice really that i can
give you is don't worry too much about
knowing every nlp
algorithm out there don't worry too much
about the newest tool out there
instead what i would do is just pick a
problem that you
think you can solve within a month or
two that's reasonably nice in a sense
that you can put it on the blog or
on your portfolio or something like that
and just solve it
like probably you're gonna get a lot of
experience uh from just solving a
problem like that
um and that'll be in the end i think
just a little bit more useful
than understanding the latest and
greatest in deep learning for machine
learning processing
this is my personal experience at least
but i would focus on
pick a problem and try to solve that
instead that should be the starting
point
that's what i usually do i just get
started and get my hands dirty but then
a professor um whom i know told me to to
um um you know go back a little bit and
and dig a bit deeper into the basics and
are you stationed are you actually i'm i
graduated
i just graduated i mean so the way i
like the
personal experience again right but i
think if you're in university that's
also the time to make like theoretical
investments in your life like
um when you're you know when you have a
job and a family and stuff you know you
have a little bit less time to properly
read all these mathematical books if
you're in university and your professor
is telling you
invest in this now i think that's still
pretty good advice
the thing though is like if i think
about all the problems that i solved in
university and i think about the
problems that i solve now
in university all the problems were like
pretty clean it's like you get a clean
data set
uh you can do everything inside of a
jupiter notebook and then
looking back it feels a little bit more
like i'm solving an exercise
than solving an actual problem because
actual problems at actual companies
are messy the data sets are super dirty
like it's hard to get data in the first
place
there's all these compromises that have
been made it's a different environment
it's i think the problems that you said
that you face in industry
don't necessarily compare very well to
what people do in
uh academia now again it's also not my
background so i don't want to
have too much of a judgment on it but
from my perspective it doesn't
necessarily seem a requirement
to really go in depth into deep learning
that's that's the main thing that i have
at least noticed
the most successful chat bots that i
have heard of
are designed by listening to users not
because someone in the team wrote the
best algorithm
my experience so far at least well yeah
um the thing is
you know when you graduate at the time
of chronovirus and you have
nothing to do um i think it's a good
idea to to
fall back a bit and dig um sure uh sure
but let me put it this way
um what do you think it's better to
learn
a new math trick or maybe a new python
library
well um depends on what you need
sure exactly so
so it's probably better to focus in on
the problem
one thing you can do though is you can
say well i want to learn this tool
so i'm going to look for a problem where
i'm forced to learn the tool
that can be fine maybe a cloud provider
right
if you've never let's say you want to
analyze a data set that doesn't
that's bigger than the memory on your
laptop you might need to do a tricks
with spark or
some cloud provider that can be super
useful um
but i but again like the main thing i
want to get across is don't feel obliged
to focus on the deep learning or the
coolest algorithm
mainly because libraries like raza and
spacey we try to make it easy for you
such that you don't need to be an expert
on the algorithm it's going to become a
commodity
you also don't have to write your own
linear regression anymore because
psychic learn has it
um yeah two lines of code and that's
like
um have a course i mean
like for for logistic regression and uh
let's say in psychic learn right
sure it's two lines of code and that's
fine but if your data set's imbalanced
you can still do the class weight trick
is that a psychic learn right
i would argue that even if you don't
write your own logistic regression
it's more important to focus on the
problem let's say one that's super
imbalanced and you know how to deal with
that
then that you write your own logistic
regression to me that feels like a cool
exercise but a waste of time if i'm
trying to solve a problem
yeah i'm i mean unless you are trying to
do fundamental research
it wouldn't really do you so much
if you want to do fundamental research
by all means go for it right i mean
there's people who want to become a phd
that's perfectly fine
um it's just that in my experience
um the most progress is made by just
thinking about the problem
i think one example that might be nice
to share
so if people are interested i have this
uh youtube channel
uh on behalf of raza it's called the
algorithm whiteboard
and basically what i try to do there is
i just try to explain algorithms that
our community members find confusing
so if you're interested in like
transformers or bert or some of that
stuff
it's just me explaining like i have done
today about all these different
algorithms
the episode that i'm currently working
on is an episode that's about
toxic language which is a very very
hard problem so
in in one of these episodes what i'll be
doing is i'll be using all sorts of
pre-trained embeddings
to see if i can detect this toxic
language quite well
now the first problem in this data set
which you only unravel if you have a
look at the data set yourself
is that it's very imbalanced there are
way more
texts that are not toxic than texts that
are toxic
so any classifier will be 90 accurate if
they just say it's not toxic all the
time
that's the first issue you're gonna have
to try and tackle
the second issue is that whether or not
something is toxic
depends a lot on culture when i was a
teenager and i was on an online form
i might say something like oh man that's
totally badass
that's and which is not a you know
that's a compliment that's not a bad
thing to say
but it has the word bad and it has the
word ass in it
so most algorithms are going to fail
here
and this is just one example of how like
if you do this
toxic language detection wrong i mean
you might block all the teenagers on
your platform by accident which is
something you don't want to do
but obviously this goes further than
just teenagers this also is like
cultural and dialects and all sorts of
these things
so like if you want to solve this
problem quite quickly i hope it's clear
that you need more than grit search you
really have to like dive deep into
okay what are the things about this
problem that make it interesting
and to me at least i've always found it
to be way more rewarding
to first understand the problem and then
look for an algorithm
as opposed to the other way around um
personal experience again feel free to
fill this in if this is meaningful for
you or not but
i've always found this to be like a
rather nice approach especially if
you're interested in learning
um thank you vincent uh from your
experience what would be the
best chatbots that you that you tried
that are built on russ and they are
available
publicly i would say that maybe we can
try some like
customer sites um so we've got a few so
i'm i'm currently trying to make this
virtual game
uh like this this chatbot game i
wouldn't call it the most successful but
it's certainly the most fun to make
it's fully open source and people are
like welcome to uh to
to contribute um i think that
like if you go online uh we've got a
couple of like assistance for use cases
so if i recall correctly
uh financial bot is one
so um we have this customer support team
and they they have a couple of these
demos
so we've got this one demo here that's
let's pretend that you're a bank what
might a chatbot look like and it's just
this demo project that you can go ahead
and start with
um like again the whole point here is
that this is meant as a starting point
but there's a couple of things in here
like uh human handoff like
there's an assistant but at some point
we have to involve a human that's
implemented in here
so i would look at some of these demo
projects um
by and large though a lot of like the
main
almost i think it's safe to say the main
the main use case for these raza
assistants is like
um customer service so
probably a lot of frequently asked
questions like that's a use case
but which frequently asked questions
apply for you depends on your company
but that if if you're looking for like
an afternoon project with like your team
making a frequently asked questions
bought for your own slack channel might
be like a fun little project to also get
started with
those are things that i recommend
thanks
and if i may add i think you can uh
connect rather with whatsapp and also
facebook messenger
so this can be also fun to make like uh
there's a couple of things still missing
like probably next quarter i'll be
looking into making this work for
discord
um because that's getting popular too um
but yeah slack works whatsapp works
text messages work there's a bunch of
services you have to check the docs for
more information but we
we try to cover most things there
awesome um and i think you should jump
by the
discord hype train with the rulers of
their ipo
that would be a good idea and if nothing
else it's fun to make right i mean it's
always fun to make new tools and new
connections and stuff it's
part of the cool job sure
um i guess we're almost at our time
uh thank you very much visit for taking
the time to tell us about
raza showing us this amazing
example of orthopedics in arabic um and
showing us the
the the library you will learn i know
myself
i'm going to spend hours playing with
that lately
so so by the way human learn there's
like a video tutorial on the website as
well
in case you're interested if there's any
issues with it though
immediately let me know on github
because i
i like to think that it will work for
arabic but if it doesn't i have to know
as soon as possible sure definitely
um and thank you all for joining us at
this cool talk
uh don't forget to check out our our
twitter page at paediatric
and also please provide your feedback on
what
visit showed us on either of the
libraries he demonstrated
this evening either to directly to visit
on our twitter or
github or on this google form that we're
going to share
and one last thing i had to get over to
dania
thank you okay so with this we conclude
our talks for the year 2020
and i just want to say thank you again
vincent i also want to say thank you
everyone
without you this would have wouldn't
have been possible so thank you for
joining us
uh we hope that the year 2021 will be
first a much more safer year around the
globe
and secondly an exciting and interesting
chapter in
by data rep chapter where we have
workshop talks and sprints
for everyone to enjoy and just make a
very great community out of so uh
yeah stay tuned everyone and see you
soon
thanks for organizing thank you
thank you vincent thank you yes sweet